[Música]
[Aplausos]
começa a minha fala rememorando junto
com vocês um período bastante
significativo no contexto brasileiro
bastante atual inclusive minha filha até
o ano de 2013 onde a história brasileira
foi marcada por um conjunto de
expressões um conjunto de manifestações
nas quais o dentre as quais acredito que
vários de vocês participaram seja com a
bandeira seja com um cartaz ou mesmo a
partir de um acompanhamento em directo
nas redes sociais na internet e na
televisão
minha filha aqui as grandes
manifestações que tomaram as ruas
brasileiras no ano 2013 e ficaram
conhecidas como jornadas de junho ou que
uma vela brasileira
esse movimento acabou entrando para a
história e traz pra gente uma série de
pistas para entender um pouco de como a
constituição nacional democrático
brasileiro acabou sendo marcado
historicamente por essa por esse
fenômeno
obviamente quando quero fazer aqui uma
análise profunda sobre esse movimento
mas uma característica central é muito
importante agente efetuar uma análise
desse cenário e aqui eu me refiro à
forma como esse movimento se organizou
se estruturou se mobilizou efetivamente
um elemento central foi justamente a
internet e as tecnologias da informação
e da comunicação as redes sociais
é interessante perceber que o que
aconteceu em 2013
havia sido estudado há tempos por um dos
pesquisadores que todos os pesquisadores
apontaram que não existe ressonância
alguma entre movimento que acontecia por
exemplo nas redes sociais na internet e
obviamente aquilo que acontecia nas ruas
aquilo que acontecia periodicamente ou
poderia acontecer por exemplo
manifestações
essa dissonância que muitos
pesquisadores apontava é foi obviamente
por terra em 2013
só pra mostrar pra vocês o que a gente
vence a
antes de 2013 em 2008 aconteceu um
movimento chamado fora sarney
o falecido continuando esse movimento é
a melhor avaliar as pessoas milhões de
pessoas discutindo temos é que
criticamos propondo alternativas contudo
quando existe um tipo de proposição para
que ele fosse às ruas fossem as praças
nenhuma nenhuma doença de pessoas
conseguiria ser conseguir ser mobilizada
para que sócrates faz a cabeça muito
esse ano ou seja efetivamente ficava
preso na internet ficava preso
a indignação que ela presa nas redes
sociais o que acaba sendo interessante
marcante no caso das manifestações 2013
é que as pessoas saem do facebook o
movimento de fatos a internet vai para
as ruas tomar as ruas em um momento é
com várias vozes com várias idéias com
várias propostas várias demandas tão
diversas quanto criativas e obviamente
acaba sendo interessante pra que a gente
entenda esse cenário que ela
manifestações sobre o transporte sobre
serviços públicos sobre qualidade da
educação a qualidade da saúde e
obviamente premiando tudo isso nós temos
a demanda mais gritante que a demanda
por mais participação uma demanda para
que as pessoas tivessem suas vozes é de
algum modo atendidos como um clamor
colocar para o próprio estado
essas demandas e esse episódio como um
todo coloca para administração pública
coloca para a democracia brasileira em
conjunto de desafios
o conjunto desafios que ainda tem que
ser digerido ainda tem que ser
trabalhado mas obviamente se faz cada
vez mais central que seja considerado
começando profissional democrático vale
a pena a gente entender que a democracia
no formato como está hoje é ainda
entendido como um campo de disputa no
campo de disputa onde conceitos
diferentes ea própria prática dela podem
ser significados e risco
picadas é interessante perceber por
exemplo que a marcha sem defende e
argumenta que a democracia é grande
conquista da humanidade no século vídeo
a gente tentar ter um pouquinho da
dimensão do que significa isso para
todos nós
obviamente ainda estamos muito longe
daquela aspiração revolucionária que é a
democracia logo é no começo de sua
história
ainda estamos muito distantes de uma
efetivação do que é a democracia
podemos dizer talvez de modo até 1o
triste que a democracia na atualidade se
apresenta os resumos a grosso modo ao
voto que ela se apresenta e se resume a
grosso modo ao sufrágio
isso é muito pouco muito pouco
considerando a democracia enquanto o
poder de fato o controle do governo e
lembre-se é exercido pelo povo a
conduzir todas as suas seus desafios
todas as suas demandas junto ao estado
a gente tem muito a caminhar para fazer
de fato a democracia sair dessa
estrutura razão dessa estrutura por
vezes rasteiro e de fala ser convertido
em ao que tenha potencial para
transformar a sociedade
hoje a democracia acaba sendo muitas
vezes lida apenas enquanto a sua forma
se eu tenho sufrágio se eu tenho voto
tem democracia
como eu disse é muito pouco democracia
vai a leilão
além do bola ela precisa ir além do blog
ela vota obviamente indo além entendendo
por exemplo e se a lei inclui
efetivamente a participação da sociedade
a participação dos cidadãos a
participação dos atores que compõem a
sociedade como um todo trazendo
problemas trazendo soluções e
construindo coletivamente essas
alternativas e isso acaba sendo
interessante é perceber democracia não
só enquanto forma mas também enquanto
forma também quanto conteúdo
isso é central para que a gente consiga
superar e mesmo entender um pouco da
semana
as ações acabaram acontecendo e tomar no
brasil em 2013
é fundamental a gente tendo por exemplo
que a democracia precisa ser
democratizado
como diz boaventura de sousa santos
talvez uma democracia mais intensa uma
democracia nas falas boaventura que vai
da cama a fábrica
óbvio que a gente tem um percurso muito
grande pra caminhar enquanto sociedade
enquanto coletivo está que isso de fato
se completa uma realidade
do mesmo modo que esse desafio posto
para toda a sociedade brasileira quando
discutir democracia a partir do prisma e
do advento do movimento em 2013
a própria administração pública também
se depara em conjunto de desafios
absolutamente interessantes é
absolutamente urgente
observe que a administração pública em
especial tem que lidar com as demandas
que são colocados pela sociedade e que
ao mesmo tempo parecem ser contraditória
para lançar a sociedade pede mais
agilidade mais velocidade e menos
burocracia
ao mesmo tempo ela quer também mais
participação que quer ser ouvida até ter
um controle social como é que eu vou ser
ao mesmo tempo rápido ágil e ouvir todos
dar espaço pra todos
são coisas que podem soar contraditórias
ouvir as pessoas das bases para a
participação demanda efetivamente
demanda efetivamente tempo de mandar
efetivamente o trabalho de cotização não
é algo feito da noite para o dia
e essa característica central para a
gente entender talvez o desafio é
colocar que é colocado como
compatibilizar esse cenário como
compatibilizar essas tensões que ao
mesmo tempo me cobram agilidade e tempo
para discussão tempo para debates feio
para participação
e aqui talvez uma um ensaio para essa
resposta a uma sugestão que eu convido
vocês a refletir
mil pode ser pensar tudo isso ou
integrar tudo isso a partir daquela
característica que eu disse no começo de
minha fala e que é o que foi utilizado
para mobilizar os movimentos sociais é
em 2013
me refiro aqui as tecnologias da
informação e da comunicação
talvez empregando tais técnicas no
âmbito da gestão pública
a gente tem condição de dar voz para
mais pessoas
temos condição de a aplicar a
capilaridade daquela ferramenta e desse
modo trazer essa informação para que a
decisão como de obviamente fique de
acordo com aquilo que a sociedade que é
a sede da informação e internet em
especial pelo seu formato comunicação
carrega esse potencial que muitas vezes
é subexplorado as tecnologias da
informação quando combinadas por exemplo
com essa ideia de democracia e
participação
ela pode ela pode potencializar todas
essas vozes que muitas vezes ficam
escondidas que agora começa a agarrar a
corpo nas ruas eça potencialização
efetivamente essa concretização
efetivamente pode se dar a partir dessas
tecnologias e aqui obviamente um meio
fio uma tecnologia um mercadológica pura
e simplesmente a tecnologia que eu penso
aqui que eu trago pra gente refletir a
tecnologia social
a tecnologia aberta software livre que
tem um caráter muito ligado com o
próprio modelo de democracia porque a
vez de comentar uma democracia mais
democratizado ante uma democracia de
conteúdo que tem efetivamente condição
de trazer para todos os nomes de trazer
para a sociedade uma lógica de
construção coletiva e se esse é o modelo
que pode ser empregado a gente pensar
numa transformação social e pensar
inclusive uma inovação social integrando
democracia
participação e tecnologias podemos
pensar numa renovação social e mais uma
vez aqui não me refiro inovação
mercadológico mais uma inovação que
tenha na própria cidadania atores
centrais para a sua constituição a
inovação aberta que seja por hora por
exemplo aos diferentes olhares porosa
por exemplo a diferentes problemas
entendendo que não só o conhecimento
científico que vai construir alguma
realidade nova uma realidade de fato o
formador o próprio conhecimento popular
quando combinado com o conhecimento
coletivo tem condição de trazer soluções
muito efetivos para os problemas que a
gente vence o nosso cotidiano para
problemas que nos afligem a tempos essa
característica avançando central a gente
pensar nessa transformação a gente
pensar nessa mudança de realidade e para
tentar mostrar tudo isso gostaria de
conversar com vocês sobre três
experiências bem interessantes que fazem
essa combinação
a primeira delas é o orçamento
participativo digital orçamento
participativo é uma ferramenta da década
de 80 na qual as pessoas é inserir em
idéias
as discussões sobre o orçamento
municipal
só para ilustrar só para deixar claro
para todos é parte a parte do orçamento
municipal que a prefeitura que a cidade
é executado obviamente a situação
pública da importância desse item para
que a gente tem é enquanto uma
característica o premiado com uma
característica democratizar o orçamento
participativo digital faz com que essa
dinâmica de discussão da peça
orçamentária aconteça um âmbito da
própria internet
então a cidadania às pessoas poderiam
opinar sobre o que transformar a
sociedade a partir da internet que o
smartphone telefone 0 800 por exemplo o
brasil foi pioneiro nessa experiência em
2006 na cidade de belo horizonte
e é interessante perceber que a gente
combinando essa dinâmica de trazer
opções trazer trazer visões e e espero
que as pessoas participem interno pode
ser muito efetivo para conseguir uma
nova realidade
um outro exemplo que eu trago para vocês
foi lá no rio grande do sul operado anos
de um governo estadual em 2010 2009 2010
chamado gabinete digital
gabriel chutar bastante interessante
porque diferente o app do orçamento
participativo ele estava em uma loja bem
mais integrada e tem por exemplo uma
dimensão muito forte que a dimensão do
controle social a dimensão dada a
inserção da cidadania da população no
controle de problemas no controle de
obras públicas por exemplo o gabinete
digital tem como mérito fazer uma
ligação direta entre a cidadania o
governo sem intermediários imediato
obviamente pela internet e isso faz toda
a diferença
um exemplo que o time pra vocês já uma
das funções da funcionalidade do
gabinete digital envolve por exemplo a
fiscalização de obras
acho que todos já se depararam com uma
placa como essa uma placa de obra
pública
mas você tem formações táticas sobre por
exemplo o valor da obra características
enfim é só você só acaba sendo essa
placa pois isso acaba sendo muito
limitada em termos de informações para o
controle social o gabinete digital foi
uma coisa bastante interessante
as obras que eram conduzidos pelo poder
público recebeu placas como essa mas
também recebiam códigos nesse formato
que o que é coaching esse tipo de código
que vocês devem encontrar por exemplo
embalagens como por exemplo
os diversos é o embalagens tipo de itens
manufaturados têm uma característica
interessante que é justamente a
capacidade de rir de você pra outras
para acesso a outras informações
então o que aconteceu esse episódio da
vida digital você tinha obra
a placa se aproximar do seu celular
esse código de barras e era
automaticamente demitido um site que
você via de modo dinâmico como aquela
obra está se desenvolvendo como aquele a
que aquele processo as etapas que estava
sendo vencemos um nome que tinha
condição desse modo tinha condições
desse modo de apontar por exemplo falam
sobre o que estava ou não em acordo ou
desacordo com aquilo que estava sendo
apontado no próprio no próprio
aplicativo e com relação à obra estava
sendo feita ali na sua frente
várias foram foram com as renúncias em
que as pessoas apontavam celular
indicado identificava percentual
terminado e viu que aquele era diferente
a realidade
obviamente que as ações acabam
acontecendo e gerou uma grande
efetividade nas práticas aquela
ferramenta ou seja mais uma vez tem uma
combinação entre democracia e tecnologia
e participação gerando melhoria dos
serviços públicos gerando melhoria da
qualidade no cade
uma terceira experiência por mais
combinada ou integrada com essa lógica
envolve o chamado laboratório vivo
colaboratório social são paulo mas temos
alguns exemplos laboratórios sociais
laboratórios vivos e ninguém também
várias experiências em laboratórios
sociais laboratório de deus
os laboratórios sociais integram cidadãs
e cidadãos integram empresários integram
organizações do terceiro setor
universidades técnicos da prefeitura
depois
mundo enfim todos discutindo
coletivamente um problema público o que
é interessante é que as partes possam
estar de modo voluntário
as alternativas são criadas a partir da
dinâmica colaborativa estabelecido entre
as pessoas
a própria participação nesse ambiente é
feito é definida pelos participantes
gerando que a gente chama de meta
participação
eu tenho nesse contexto do laboratório
vivo então uma oportunidade central para
que as pessoas consigam criar soluções a
partir dos problemas que elas vivenciam
ou seja as pessoas podem pensar
problemas sociais discutir coletivamente
e fazendo um processo de com produção do
bem público na qual todos são atores
reconhecidos como iguais todos são
atores reconhecidos com voz
todos são atores reconhecidos e
capacidade de pensar soluções para seus
problemas
então isso é uma iniciativa muito
interessante que pode ser pensada para
que a gente construa efetivamente uma
democracia muito mais efetivo nos países
onde acontece mais justa mais solidária
e que efetivamente consiga trazer para
todos nós um olhar um olhar muito mais
integrado entre os problemas sociais por
exemplo entre as diferentes é diferente
da que estamos enfrentado vários foram
os produtos saídos da experiência uma
moratória digitais e softwares e
processos dinâmicas
enfim e tudo isso nos dá esperança de
uma clareza bastante interessante que de
que quando integramos democracia
participação e tecnologia temos
condições plenas de fazer uma
transformação na sociedade
temos condições plenas de fazer uma
democracia
efetivo pois a democracia pode e deve ir
além do voto
obrigado pessoal
[Aplausos]